Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in a learning disability service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the story has reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good
嗨，我是马克斯，在西约克郡的一家学习障碍服务机构担任助理心理学家。就像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在稳步地向那个看似不可能的目标——考入临床博士学位——迈进。带着这个最终目标，我想了解一下目前的情况，看看有哪些书对此会有帮助。我偶然读到了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家合集》，并决定买下它，这对我的旅程很有帮助。我觉得玛丽安的书非常informative，充满了启发。我尤其喜欢书中的故事让我明白，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上十全十美，只要你具备良好的
interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology. It made me want to work in that field one day. Imagine chasing a psychology career dream for years, rejection after rejection and still finding the courage to keep showing up. That's the story of today's guest Jack, a trainee clinical psychologist who applied six times before finally securing his place on the doctorate. Jack's route has been anything but ordinary from football coaching in Wales to working as an assistant psychologist. He's woven his love of teamwork, mindset and motivation into a journey defined by perseverance
人际交往能力，如同理心和共情，你就能实现目标。我强烈向所有有志成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，也推荐给那些想更多了解临床心理学世界的人。它让我幻想着有一天能在这个领域工作。想象一下，多年来一直在追逐心理学职业梦想，经历了一次又一次的拒绝，却依然有勇气继续坚持下去。这就是今天嘉宾杰克的故事，他是一名临床心理学博士生，申请了六次才最终获得博士项目的录取。杰克的道路绝非寻常，从威尔士的足球教练到担任助理心理学家。他将自己对团队合作、心态和动力的热爱融入了一段由坚韧
and purpose. In this episode, we talk about what it really takes to keep believing in yourself when the system feels impossible, the self-doubt, the sacrifice and the quiet moments of resilience that get you there in the end. sometimes success in psychology isn't about being chosen, it's about choosing to keep going. Hope you find it so useful and if you do, please like, subscribe and follow for more. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist and I'm joined here today by Jack Griffith, who is a first-year trainee clinical psychologist.
和目标感定义的旅程中。在本期节目中，我们探讨了当体制看似不可能时，如何真正坚持对自己的信念，其中的自我怀疑、牺牲以及最终带你走向成功的那些安静的坚韧时刻。有时候，心理学上的成功不是关于被选择，而是关于选择继续前行。希望你会觉得这很有用，如果你觉得是的话，请点赞、订阅并关注以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到“有志心理学家”播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我一起的是杰克·格里菲斯，他是一名一年级临床心理学博士生。
Hi, Jack. Hi. Thank you so much for agreeing to come on this episode. You've been on my radar for a little while because you contributed as a case study to a chapter that I wrote on a book on auto-ethnography. So that's where you first caught my eye because you were talking about your work kind of as an academy coach and kind of the responsibility and the pleasure that it brought you, but how it helped you think about kind of psychology and psychology principles. Could you tell us a little bit about your route, Jack?
嗨，杰克。嗨。非常感谢你答应来参加这一期节目。你一直在我的关注列表上，因为你曾作为案例研究，为我写的一本关于自传性民族志的书中的一个章节做出过贡献。所以这也是你最初吸引我注意的地方，因为你谈到了你作为学院教练的工作，以及它带给你的责任感和快乐，还有它是如何帮助你思考心理学以及心理学原则的。杰克，能给我们简单讲讲你的经历吗？
Yeah, so I started coaching football around the age of 23, 24, after I had a couple of ACL injuries. Tommy ACL was the third time I've done it, so I thought it was time to hang up the boots in and delve into the world of coaching. And at the same time, I was an assistant psychologist, and I quickly discovered how important it was to kind of merge those two passions of mine and how they kind of reinforce one another and how they helped improve myself as a coach, but also as a practitioner. And that's for loads of different reasons. I think it was communication was a big one, how you interact with people, your leadership styles, and probably most importantly, the culture you create.
好的，大概在我23、24岁左右，经历了几次前十字韧带（ACL）损伤后，我开始从事足球教练工作。右侧前十字韧带受伤是我第三次遭遇这种伤病，所以我认为到了把球鞋挂起来、深入探索教练世界的时候了。与此同时，我是一名助理心理学家，我很快发现将这两个热情融合在一起有多么重要，它们如何相互强增，以及它们如何帮助我提高作为教练和从业者的能力。这有许多不同的原因。我认为沟通是一个重要方面，你如何与人互动，你的领导风格，以及可能最重要的是你创造的文化。
And as soon as I use some of the psychological principles that I've learned as an assistant, and through my undergraduate degree and whatnot, we really helped improve that culture and create a nice environment for the young lads. So a lot of the boys we were working with, with teenage of 16 and 19. So it's quite an impressionable age. Yeah, quite the responsibility as well
一旦我运用了作为助理时学到的心理学原则，以及通过我的本科学习等获得的知识，我们确实帮助改善了那种文化，并为年轻的小伙子们创造了一个良好的环境。因此，我们合作的许多男孩年龄在16到19岁之间。所以这是一个相当容易受影响的年龄。是的，这也是相当大的责任
because I think for all the boys, football is their world as it was for me for a while. Yeah, and it goes really well. I've lived a lot, developed my skills really well, and it was a really good five years. I've had lots of different roles The last role I had was Chairman of the club
因为我认为对所有这些男孩来说，足球就是他们的世界，一段时间以来对我也是如此。是的，进展非常顺利。我的技能得到了很好的发展，这是非常美好的五年。我担任过许多不同的角色，我担任的最后一个角色是俱乐部主席
So it's quite a big club in Wales In fairness I'd say it's more than a grass It was an academy at one point And I've been first team coach I've been player I've been lots of different things really And it's yes
所以它在威尔士是一个相当大的俱乐部。平心而论，我认为它不仅仅是草根足球。它一度是一个青训学院。我担任过一线队教练、球员，实际上做过很多不同的事情。是的
It's put me in good stead For training now on the On the doctorate finally Yeah absolutely And we'll talk a little bit About that word finally shortly as well But actually before we hit record
它为我现在在博士项目中的培训打下了良好的基础，终于开始了。是的，绝对的。我们稍后也会讨论“终于”这个词。但实际上在我们按下录音键之前
you told me a really lovely story about how psychology came into your life. And it's too powerful a story to not tell and not let you tell. Could you retell us that? Yeah, I think for me, psychology has been something I've been interested in probably for my teenage years. I'm something I've always been interested in, always being curious about. And you don't really learn about it at comprehensive school, doing your GCSEs. It certainly wasn't a topic we studied in school. But it was something I was drawn to.
你给我讲了一个非常美好的故事，关于心理学是如何进入你的生活。这个故事太有力量了，不讲出来或者不让你亲自讲出来实在太可惜了。你能给我们重新讲讲吗？是的，我认为对我来说，心理学可能从我青少年时期起就一直是我感兴趣的事物。这是我一直感兴趣、一直充满好奇的事物。你在综合学校读GCSE时并不会真正学到它。这绝对不是我们在学校里学习的学科。但它确实是我被吸引的东西。
I remember doing English lessons. We have to go to the library and pick books. And I was often drawn to the science and psychology section, picking up books on memory and learning the method of locale and people testing me on lists of items I can remember. And I was very curious and very passionate about that. And that led me then to psychology A levels across Keyes College. and I think the first person I spoke to on the open day
我记得在上英语课时。我们得去图书馆挑书。我经常被科学和心理学专区吸引，挑选关于记忆的书籍，学习地点记忆法，人们测试我能记住的一串物品。我对此感到非常好奇和充满热情。这随后引导我在凯斯学院学习了心理学A-Level。我想我在开放日交谈的第一个人
was the psychology teacher and it's kind of gone from there then. I've just kind of followed my interests. I think lots of people, especially on the course, they've wanted to be a clinical psychologist since they were like 17, 18, whereas for me, it's just been following what I'm interested and maybe what I'm good at as well
就是心理学老师，然后事情就从那里发展开去了。我只是顺从了自己的兴趣。我认为很多人，尤其是这个专业的人，从17、18岁起就想成为一名临床心理学家，而对我来说，这只是追随我感兴趣的事物，也许还有我擅长的东西
and what I'm drawn to. Yeah, so I've gone through a conventional route in that sense, but I feel like since I've graduated, it's been maybe a little bit more on convention, and a little bit different to most people, There's many football coaches slash trainee psychologists in the country. And, yeah, it does, it does make me sound a little bit different. And, yeah, something that I think is really complemented to each other
以及我所被吸引的事物。是的，从这个意义上说，我走了一条常规的路线，但我觉得自从毕业以来，可能稍微有点不太常规，和大多数人有点不同。全国并没有多少足球教练兼心理学博士生。而且，是的，这确实让我听起来有点与众不同，并且，是的，我认为这是相互完美互补的事情
and certainly help me in each of the areas. But also, I think it's because I enjoy both of those things as well. So if I can merge those two, I'm enjoying life, really. And that is so lovely to see, because actually sometimes people join training and they're like, oh I'm not this is not what I thought this isn't good but like you're pleased with where you're at and you know with with I guess you've still been able to I say you still feel like you I think that's kind of what's coming across yeah yeah I don't know if I've changed I probably haven't
并且肯定在各个领域都对我有所帮助。而且，我也认为这是因为我也很享受这两件事。所以如果我能将这两者结合起来，我确实在享受生活。看到这一点真是太美妙了，因为实际上有时人们加入培训时会想，哦，我不是，这不是我想象的那样，这不好，但像你一样，你对自己的现状感到满意，你知道，随着——我想你仍然能够——我说你仍然觉得你——我想这大概就是传达出来的感觉。是的，是的。我不知道自己是否改变了，我可能没有
changed much I think you'd have to ask my friends and family if I've changed me I don't think I have to be honest now I feel quite grounded and quite secure in who I am or what I enjoy and why I'm interested and I think as long as you do that And as long as you're following you, you're interested, and your passions and doing what's right for you, I think you're going to be fine. Yeah. And I did an episode with Jack Lowe. We were talking about job crafting. And that's the idea of actually being able to take your experiences, what you've learned, maybe some of the vulnerabilities there, from seemingly kind of maybe not super relevant roles, not directly clinical relevant roles anyway.
改变多少。我想你得去问我的朋友和家人我是否变了，老实说我不觉得我变了。现在我觉得自己脚踏实地，对自己的身份、自己的爱好以及自己的兴趣所在非常有安全感。我认为只要你这样做，只要你追随自己的兴趣、热情，做对你来说正确的事情，我想你会没事的。是的。我和杰克·洛录制过一集播客。我们当时在谈论工作塑形。这个概念实际上是指能够将你的经历、你学到的东西、甚至其中一些脆弱性，从看似关联度不高、无论如何与临床没有直接关联的角色中提炼出来。
Have you been able to do that a little bit from your experiences with your academy work and with the kind of young men that you've been coaching? So kind of weave into your psychology reflections and interviews and applications. Yeah, I think early on it was one of those messages you often get from people with psychology. Nearly everything is relevant. If you're working as a lifeguard like I used to do, if you're working with lots of different people, it's going to help your people skills, your interpersonal skills, which is really, really important. So I've kind of always, I suppose subconsciously maybe I've always thought about what can I take from
你是否能够从你在青训学院的工作以及你一直执教的年轻小伙子们的经历中稍微做到这一点？从而将它们融入到你的心理学反思、面试和申请中。是的，早期这是人们常对心理学说的一句话。几乎所有事情都是相关的。如果你像我以前一样当过救生员，如果你和形形色色的人工作过，它会帮助你提升人际交往能力，这真的、真的很重要。所以我某种程度上总是——我想潜意识里我一直在思考，我能从中汲取什么
this and apply it to psychology. And that's certainly what you do when you're applying for jobs and things. So thinking about how my time as a lifeguard helped me assess risk and work with people and deal with people. That was always something I thought about. So when I've had to do that with football, it was probably a lot easier because I was doing it at the same time as well. So I was literally leaving the hospital and going across the road, Nestra up and up and up to the training pitch and coaching people, coaching the young boys. And then I think at first I probably didn't bridge that gap.
并将其应用到心理学中。当你申请工作之类的时候，你肯定会这样做。所以思考我担任救生员的经历如何帮助我评估风险、与人合作以及处理人际关系。这一直是我思考的问题。所以当我在足球领域必须这样做时，可能要容易得多，因为我当时也在同时做这件事。所以我实际上是离开医院，穿过马路，径直走到训练场去指导人们，指导那些年轻男孩。然后我想起初我可能并没有弥合这个鸿沟。
It probably took a little bit of reflection, a little bit of thinking about, okay, what can I do here? And the more I learned as an assistant psychologist, the more I could apply to my role as an academy coach, as a football coach. And he thought, yeah, I started bringing in things quite literally then. And it was using things at the Oscar model and motivational interview and doing halftime team talks, for example. That was something that I thought,
这可能需要一点反思，一点思考，好吧，我在这里能做什么？我在助理心理学中学到的越多，我就越能把它应用到我作为青训教练、足球教练的角色中。他想，是的，我开始字面意义上地引入一些东西了。它使用的是诸如OSCAR模型、动机访谈法以及比如做中场休息时对球队的讲话。这是我认为
okay, this is real tangible thing I can take over quite concrete here and quite specific. And it would often be the case of asking people, okay, what have they done well this half? What can we do better? And having them come up with their own ideas, that was quite a little, I thought it was a little clever trick that they used to do at halftime. And the boys used to talk.
好吧，这是一个我可以借鉴的真实的、切实的东西，相当具体。通常的情况是问大家，好吧，他们这半场做得好的是什么？我们能做得更好的是什么？让他们自己想出主意，这挺巧妙的，我认为这是他们过去在中场休息时使用的一个小聪明技巧。而且男孩们会进行交流。
We give them autonomy. We give them competency. They feel quite related. You know, building on that self-determined. theory. And that was something I kept in mind quite often, especially because they were young boys, and I thought that was part of their game that they needed to develop. We need to create leaders and that sense of ownership on the pitch. So I've thought about that quite a lot, and that's maybe something I've talked about in the article I wrote in the psychologist as well.
我们赋予他们自主权。我们赋予他们胜任感。他们感到相当有联系感。你知道，以此建立自我决定论。这也是我经常铭记在心的东西，特别是考虑到他们是年轻男孩，我认为这是他们需要发展的比赛的一部分。我们需要在球场上培养领袖和这种主人翁意识。所以我对此进行了很多思考，这也许也是我在《心理学家》杂志上撰写的文章中谈到过的事情。
And I really learned a little bit more when I was writing an article about what I've learned as a coach and what I've applied. And then the other things are just kind of the things I learned from like child and families to think about what's happening at home for these people thinking about the ABC model or the iceberg model, all those sort of things thinking a bit more deeply about the players and they are people
当我写一篇关于我作为教练所学到的东西以及我如何应用它们的文章时，我确实了解得更多了。然后其他的事情只是我从儿童和家庭工作中学到的东西，去思考这些人在家里发生了什么，思考ABC模型或冰山模型，所有这些事情，更深入地思考球员们，而不仅仅是他们本身
and they were a good bunch of lads to work with they were lovely lads academy boys all wanted to do really well so it was quite a good quite a good bunch to to apply those psychological principles on really know the boys deeper than I think just being myself was really helpful as well
他们是一群很棒的小伙子，合作起来很愉快。他们都是可爱的青训男孩，都想把事情做好，所以应用这些心理学原则真的是非常、非常棒的一群人。了解这些男孩比仅仅做我自己更深入，这确实也很有帮助
quite an extravert I quite like people I'm curious about people anyway so I didn't have to really change my personality much at all it was just more about being yourself not trying to be like a stereotypical football coach really we are shouting and telling boys off that's not my style and as soon as I appreciate that I think I thought I enjoy it more as well and the boys responded better as well and we've had some success we've got a couple of league titles and it was a good good five years yeah amazing and i bet they'll really miss you and you'll obviously miss aspect of that you might not miss the draughty uh drafty welsh weather um i spare i'm now a football mum i have a whole coat that i've bought um i've got a whole outfit um yeah if it's raining
我性格挺外向的，我很喜欢人，反正我对人也充满好奇，所以我根本不需要真正改变自己的性格。这更多的是关于做自己，不要试图表现得像个刻板印象中的足球教练，总是冲着男孩们大喊大叫、训斥他们，那不是我的风格。一旦我意识到了这一点，我想我也开始更享受它了，男孩们的回应也更好了，我们取得了一些成功，我们赢得了几个联赛冠军，这是美好、美好的五年。是的，太棒了，我敢打赌他们会非常想念你，而你显然也会想念那里的某些方面，你可能不会想念那些有穿堂风的、呃，风很大的威尔士天气……我猜，我现在是一个足球妈妈了，我买了一整套外套，我有一整套装备……是的，如果下雨
or windy it's not always the most pleasant place to be is it um and as we're talking like Like, I'm really thinking about your experience of also, you know, being male and psychology and even picking up that psychology book and, you know, asking your mates to quiz you on kind of brain parts. Like, that can't have been that easy even being different. I'm guessing most of your friends probably weren't picking up psychology books. But maybe they were. Maybe this is like, you know, the friendship group that you had.
或刮风，那不总是最宜人的地方，对吧？呃，当我们谈论时，就像，我真的在思考你作为男性的经历，以及你在心理学领域的经历，甚至拿起那本心理学心理学书，呃，让你的死党们考你关于大脑各部分的问题。即使与众不同，这也一定没那么容易。我猜你的大多数朋友可能不会拿起心理学书。但也可能他们会。也许这就像，你知道，你拥有的朋友圈。
But raising your head up and being like, actually, I'm going to pursue psychology. I want to ultimately be a qualified psychologist one day and I'm male. Could you talk to us a little bit about that? Yeah, it's an interesting concept because I think when I was growing up, especially in comprehensive school, and even when I went to A-levels, I didn't see it as like a female-dominated profession. Actually, I don't think my friends do either. So the friends who haven't really worked in psychology, they probably would have given me a bit of stick
但你昂起头说，实际上，我要追求心理学。我最终希望有一天能成为一名合格的心理学家，而且我是个男性。你能跟我们聊聊这个吗？是的，这是一个有趣的概念，因为我认为自我成长过程中，特别是在综合学校时，甚至当我攻读A-Level时，我并没有把它视为一个女性主导的行业。实际上，我认为我的朋友们也没有。所以那些没有真正在心理学领域工作过的朋友，他们可能会因为
for working with like a female I don't think they know so hopefully they don't see this part of the podcast but it's nothing I thought of either and I think mainly that's because if you think of some of the famous psychologists they tend to be men I think some of them are prominent ones at the moment
我和女性一起工作而给我一点难堪。我想他们并不知道，所以希望他们看不到播客的这一部分，但这也是我没有想过的，而且我认为这主要是因为如果你想想一些著名的心理学家，他们往往是男性。我认为目前其中一些杰出的人
it tends to be more men and it was only until I remember quite vividly I walked into Manchester University Open Day and it must have been like 80% 80% girls there and my dad turned to me
往往更多是男性，直到我生动地记得，我走进曼彻斯特大学的开放日，那里一定有大约80%、80%的女孩，我爸爸转向我
I can see why you want to do psychology now I think I didn't know about this. This is kind of the first time I've realized it was female dominated. And then I've gone into the undergraduate. And you see it's like, you know, 75%, 80% women on the course. And it's the same now when you go to go into clinical. For me, I've kind of enjoyed that. I think growing up, I got two brothers, all my cousins are boys,
我能理解为什么你现在想学心理学了。我想我以前不知道这一点。这是我第一次意识到它是女性主导的。然后我进入了本科学习。你看到课程里大约有75%、80%是女性。现在你去攻读临床专业也是一样的。对我来说，我其实挺享受这一点的。我想在成长过程中，我有两个兄弟，我所有的表兄弟都是男孩
all my mates with boys, really. I was very much a football rugby kind of guy who would spend all this time with boys. At one point you could say, you know, would it be difficult working with whether it hasn't been at all? I've really enjoyed it. And I think it's quite enjoyable being sometimes the only man or one of the few men's on the team because you do bring something new. You do have different insights and different perspectives on things and you do feel quite valued.
我所有的朋友也都是男孩。我基本上是一个足球橄榄球那种类型的家伙，会把所有的时间都花在男孩身上。有时你可能会说，你知道，和女性一起工作会困难吗？一点也不。我真的很享受。而且我觉得有时成为团队中唯一的男性或少数男性之一其实挺有趣的，因为你确实带来了新的东西。你对事情确实有不同的见解和不同的视角，而且你确实觉得自己很有价值。
Yeah, so I've kind of enjoyed it. It does, I think it is a little bit harder for some men in psychology. I think it's certainly hard to, let me talk about before, show your vulnerability and open up and be really reflective. I feel like maybe men start a few years behind. It takes a little bit longer to catch up. I feel like women's maybe got maybe more of a running start at that. But as soon as you're able to develop those skills and learn them,
是的，所以我其实挺享受这个过程的。我觉得对于心理学领域的某些男性来说，这确实要难一些。以前我想说的是，表现出你的脆弱、敞开心扉并进行深刻的反思，对男性来说绝对是不容易的。我觉得可能男性在这方面起步要落后几年，需要更长的时间才能赶上。相比之下，女性在这方面可能更有领先优势。但只要你能够培养并学会这些技能，
it does become easier. But I think it's something I thought about a lot. Is it a positive or negative? And remember when I first started off, my supervisor said you're going to have to work a little bit harder in clinical psychology because you're a man. I took over the pinch of thought, it's not going to be like that, it's going to be fine. It's very, all the talk around equality and diversity and, you know, people will acknowledge that.
事情就会变得容易一些。不过我对此也思考了很多：这究竟是积极的还是消极的？我记得刚开始的时候，我的督导对我说，在临床心理学领域，由于你是男性，你可能得付出更多的努力。我当时有点没当回事，心想事情不会这样的，会挺顺利的。大家都一直在谈论平等和多样性，你知道的，大家会承认这一点的。
And he was probably right when I look back. Yeah, so it's full of challenge, but it's full of opportunities as well, I think, being one of the few men in the course, it does allow you to do maybe things that other people don't. Yeah, and that question and kind of, the conversation had come up because, because like I said, well, as soon as I got your submissions for the auto-ethnography chapter, like, I just was really taken by the way that you'd, you know, submitted them and what you'd written, and even the length of what you'd written on the survey, like, it was just really impressive. And I, and I kind of said to you, well, how long has it taken you to get to where you are now? And you were like, oh, sort of lost
现在回想起来，他当时可能是对的。是的，充满挑战，但也充满机遇。作为课程中为数不多的几名男性之一，我觉得这确实能让你去做一些其他人可能做不到的事情。是的，之所以会有这个话题和对话，是因为就像我刚才说的，自从我收到你们关于自传民族志章节的提交材料后，我真的被你们提交的方式、写的内容深深吸引了，甚至连你们在问卷上写的内容的长度都让我印象深刻。我就对你说过，你走到今天这一步花了多长时间？然后你说，哦，我都快记不清了，
account really but maybe like about six six applications and like so you've really kept trying but does is it okay to ask how old you are yeah I was 31 in January okay so you're not we're not super much older than most people but it's how you've kept going and actually the choices you've made so you are Welsh and you've never lived outside of Wales But actually, you know, you have had reserve place offers for the University of South Wales, but last year that didn't come about and you were like, actually, I've got this place offer at this uni and I'm going for it. I'm taking control and I'm, you know, I'm leaving the country
大概有六次申请吧。所以你一直在坚持尝试。请问你多大了？我一月份刚满31岁。好吧，所以你其实并没有比大多数人年长很多，但关键在于你是如何坚持下来的，以及你做出的选择。你是威尔士人，而且从未在威尔士以外的地方生活过。但事实上，你曾获得过南威尔士大学的候补录取资格，但去年那个机会没能实现，而你当时的想法是，其实我已经拿到了这所大学的录取通知，我要抓住它。我要掌控自己的生活，你知道的，我要离开这个抚养我长大的国家，
that has been, has raised me. You know, that's not an easy decision to make, but I'm really pleased that it's working out for you. But really in psychology, because of the small nature, I think of assistant jobs as well and certainly doctoral places, people will often move, will uproot their entire life. I only moved from the kind of Milton Keynes area to Coventry, but I still did it. Still got all of my belongings moved, you know? And it's not a small thing to do, is it? Like, but it's that passion that drives you. Yeah, I was always taking aback when I hear people move from like London and parts of England to work in Newport for an assistant role.
这可不是一个容易作出的决定，但我真的很高兴事情对你来说有了好的结果。不过在心理学领域，由于助理岗位的规模很小，博士生名额也很少，人们经常需要搬迁，需要连根拔起搬到别处生活。我当时只是从米尔顿凯恩斯地区搬到了考文垂，但我还是照做了。把所有的行李都搬了过去，你知道吗？这可不是件小事，对吧？但这正是驱动你的热情所在。是的，每当听说有人从伦敦或英格兰的其他地方搬到纽波特去做助理工作，我总是感到很惊讶。
So people move for assistant roles, which is it's not something I probably would have done, to be honest. There's plenty of opportunities in South Wales. I did work in Powers for a bit, which was like an hour there, an hour back commute. And that was quite tough, especially when the fuel prices were as high as they were. I think it was 2022, 21, when it was like 200 litre for diesel. Yeah, people do do it. And it is so competitive. I think that's why people do it.
所以人们会为了助理岗位而搬迁，说实话，这可能是我不会做的事。南威尔士有的是机会。我曾在波伊斯工作过一段时间，那里的通勤是一小时去、一小时回。这挺不容易的，特别是当油价像当时那么高的时候。我想那是2022年或2021年，柴油价格大约是每升200便士。是的，确实有人这么做。竞争太激烈了，我想这就是人们这样做的原因。
It's that over-competitiveness. But it's also, for a lot of people, I feel clinical psychology is the only route that's feasible for them due to the funding, due to the cost. I think that's why there's that, seeing that bottleneck you see. And unfortunately, lots of graduates in psychology, they don't use that degree directly. They go off and do other things because they see clinical psychologists, is not a feasible option for them.
竞争实在太卷了。但对许多人来说，我也觉得临床心理学是他们唯一可行的途径，因为涉及到资金和成本问题。我想这就是为什么你会看到那种瓶颈效应。不幸的是，许多心理学毕业生并没有直接使用这个学位，他们转行去做别的了，因为他们觉得临床心理学家对他们来说并不是一个可行的选择。
You do need a little bit of luck. You do need a bit of good timing. I was lucky in a way that I got my first assistant role sort of nine months after my master's. I don't know how long I would have stuck at doing it, but I didn't realize how much I enjoyed until I did it. So that, you know, I was lucky I got a foot in the door failure early on in my career.
你确实需要一点运气，也需要赶上好的时机。从某种意义上说我很幸运，我在硕士毕业大约九个月后就得到了第一份助理工作。我不知道如果没找到我会坚持多久，但在亲身体验之前，我并没有意识到自己有多喜欢它。所以，你知道的，我很幸运在职业生涯的早期就踏入了这扇门。
And then that year and roles you enjoy. So that always helps. Yeah, certainly this year, when I was on the reserve list for Cardiff this year, and I didn't get an interview again. and that's kind of the second time I haven't got an interview after having an interview. And I finally said I'm an interview really tough. I didn't think I did as well as maybe the Cardiff courses,
然后那一年以及你喜欢的工作岗位，总是会有所帮助的。是的，确实是今年，当我在卡迪夫大学的候补名单上，却再次没有得到面试机会时，这已经是我在获得过一次面试后第二次没有得到面试了。我最后觉得面试真的很难。我觉得自己表现得可能不如卡迪夫大学那些课程的要求，
but I must have done something right. But I remember speaking to my supervisor saying, I'm kind of done with this. Now I can't, because I'm 31, I'm still an assistant. People around me are getting on, but I'm not getting it. I don't know why I'm doing wrong. I can't do much more. I've got publications, all these different roles.
但我肯定也做对了一些事情。不过我记得当时和我的督导交谈时说，我真的对这个感到厌倦了。现在我撑不下去了，因为我都31岁了，却还只是个助理。身边的同龄人都在进步，而我却毫无进展。我不知道自己哪里做错了，我已经做到了极致。我有发表的论文，做过各种不同的角色。
I've worked in research. I've worked across the lifespan. I can't do anymore. Yeah, and I was kind of done with it, to be honest. And I was starting to think of other things to do, maybe going back and study in medicine or going and working in a completely different field where I can bring more money quickly.
我在研究领域工作过，也接触过各个年龄段的人群。我真的无能为力了。是的，说实话，我当时真的打算放弃了。我甚至开始考虑做点别的，也许重新回去学医，或者去一个能让我更快赚到更多钱的完全不同的领域工作。
But thankfully, last it to attend, I got on. And yeah, I haven't looked back, really. I'm just pleased I go on because it is, I think this is the field that I'm suited to the best, and this is where I feel most comfortable. it suits my skills and it's probably here I can go the furthest end so but for lots of people they don't get the rubber the green they don't get the luck or they don't they haven't got the ability to move away for whatever reason whereas the financial or personal reasons they
但谢天谢地，最后一次申请我被录取了。是的，我此后没有再回过头看。我只是很高兴我被录取了，因为我认为这是最适合我的领域，也是我感到最舒适的地方。它符合我的技能，可能也是我能走得最远的地方。但对于很多人来说，他们没有那么幸运，没有得到那抹绿灯，或者由于种种原因无法搬到外地去，无论是出于经济还是个人原因，他们
they can't move from london to from where else to london or to liverpool or glasgow or wherever because they've got other things going on absolutely and I think you before we started recording you'd say actually it's actually really hard to kind of go into an interview where you've never met them before, you don't know anything about them, and to then be really vulnerable, you know, from a standing start.
无法从伦敦搬到其他地方，或者从其他地方搬到伦敦、利物浦、格拉斯哥或任何地方，因为他们还有其他事情要处理。完全同意。我想你在我们开始录音之前说过，其实要走进一个你从未见过面、对对方一无所知，还要在一无所有的情况下表现得非常脆弱，这真的很难。
And I guess this is what we ask our clients to do as well, isn't it? But you kind of said that actually that's really, it feels tricky because that's not necessarily something that you do regularly. It takes you time to build those relationships. So that's maybe an additional barrier to getting, kind of, to getting you in the profession. Yeah, I think during my Saddam's, for example, I'm sat there
我想这也是我们要求来访者去做的，对吧？但你当时说过，这其实感觉很棘手，因为这不一定是你会经常做的事情。你需要时间去建立那些关系。所以这可能是进入这个行业的一个额外障碍。是的，我觉得在我的面试中，比如说，我坐在那里，
and there's three or four women looking back at me and I'm thinking, I've been told time and time again, I need to show vulnerability, and I need to do this, I know you do that. But it's almost like it's ingrained in you not to do that, and your gut feeling is saying don't show your vulnerability, don't show your weakness here. And sometimes, yeah, you just can't do it, even though you feel like that's the thing to do,
有三四个女性看着我，我在想，我一次又一次被告知，我需要展现脆弱，我需要这样做，我知道你们是这么做的。但这就好像你内心里根深蒂固地认为不能这样做，你的直觉在告诉你不要展现脆弱，在这里不要表现出你的弱点。有时候，是的，你就是做不到，尽管你觉得那是应该做的事，
which is a bit, I felt that's quite a natural. and that's not me then being authentic. It's almost like, I got to say something, I got to show a weakness, you have vulnerability, because that's what they like. So it's kind of the whole interview mentality then, I suppose, where you're doing things, you want to be yourself, but also you've got to sort of play the game a little bit,
我觉得这有点不自然。这并不是真正的我。这就好像，我必须说点什么，我必须表现出弱点，展现脆弱，因为那是他们喜欢的。所以我觉得这就像是整个面试的心态，你在做一些事情，你既想做自己，但同时又不得不陪他们玩这个游戏，
and I didn't like that part of the interview, I suppose, where you've got to do things that doesn't feel natural to you. I think when you're in a stressful environment and you get one shot of this, otherwise you've got to do the whole stressful, rigorous, decline application again and wait another year and you're still in the system role that pressure does get you and you do go back to what you know and what you feel safe doing and that is you know what men do best is just saying everything's fine and getting on the things and saying yeah it's
我想我不喜欢面试中的那部分，因为你必须去做一些让你觉得不自然的事情。我觉得当你处于一个充满压力的环境，而且你只有这一次机会，否则你就得再次经历那种充满压力、严苛的拒绝申请流程，再等上一年，而你依然只是个助理，这种压力真的会压垮你，你会退回到你熟悉、让你感到安全的事情上去，那就是——你知道的，男人最擅长的就是说一切都很好，然后继续干活，说一切都
great and I definitely did that in the Southampton interview maybe towards the end I did I was I was able to express that but even in the feedback it was like yeah shows a bit more vulnerability but for men that's really hard the conditioned for the last 30 years not to do that really really so yeah and it's whether we can i guess as supervisors um either male or supervise male or female supervisors it's whether we can i guess really recognize that and really try to use supervision as a space not just for client protection and kind of case management but to think about vulnerability and trying to weave in that and and reflect is that something that's been done with you in supervision? Do you think that's something that would be beneficial to do more
很好。我在南安普顿的面试中确实这么做了，也许到了最后，我能够表达出来，但即使在反馈中，他们还是说：表现出更多的脆弱性。但对男性来说，这真的很难。他们在过去30年里受到的教育就是不要那样做，真的非常难。所以，是的，我想作为督导——无论是男督导还是女督导，我们是否真的能够认识到这一点，并努力将督导不仅仅作为一个保护来访者和案例管理的场所，而是作为一个思考脆弱性、将这一点融入其中并进行反思的空间？你在督导中经历过这样的事情吗？你认为多做这方面的工作会有益吗？
of? Can you do it now as a trainee, for example? I feel like, yeah, when you get on the course, you do feel a little bit more confident, a little bit more relaxed. As an assistant, you're still on that kind of rat race a little bit. You're trying to get on and you're trying to get to the next checkpoint. You're trying to do the best you can. I think it probably takes more than just supervision once a week with a clinical psychologist who you're working with. I think to break down those barriers and change how men think it's going to take more than that I think it's more about changing more taking into consideration how men work in psychology and and adhering to those needs rather than trying to change the men because I feel like the system at the moment does
你现在作为一名培训生能做到这一点吗？我觉得，是的，当你进入课程后，你会觉得稍微更有自信一点，也更放松一点。作为一名助理，你仍然身处那种激烈的竞争中，试图向前迈进，试图到达下一个检查点。你试图做到最好。我想这可能需要的不仅仅是每周与你共事的临床心理学进行一次督导。我认为要打破这些障碍并改变男性的思维方式，需要的远不止这些。这更多的是关于改变，更多地考虑到男性在心理学领域的工作方式，并顺应这些需求，而不是试图去改变男性，因为我觉得目前的系统确实
suit women more because of that emphasis on reflection and showing vulnerability whereas it's really hard for men to do that I think thinking about it is not the problem we're able to reflect and think about it's just verbalising it and putting that out to especially around women women you don't know. But yeah, when you get comfortable in supervision, I feel like that's been the case. But at the same time, I think it's easier to reflect and share your vulnerability
因为过于强调反思和展现脆弱而更适合女性，而这对于男性来说真的很难做到。我认为思考并不是问题所在，我们能够进行反思和思考，只是很难将之诉诸语言并表达出来，特别是在不认识的女性面前。但是，是的，当你在督导中感到舒适时，我觉得情况就会有所不同。但与此同时，我认为与一个你能产生共鸣的人进行反思和分享脆弱会更容易，
with someone you can relate to. But that's difficult as a man in psychology because there's very few people like us in the profession. So, yes, it's a difficult balancing act to have. And it's something that I think should be taken into consideration more. It is difficult. then we talk about equality and diversity and inclusion
但这作为心理学领域的男性来说是困难的，因为在这个行业中像我们这样的人非常少。所以，是的，这是一个艰难的平衡。我认为这应该是需要更多被考虑的事情。这确实很难。然后我们谈论平等、多样性和包容性，
and trying to make things as accessible for everybody. But unfortunately, I don't feel like men are brought into that conversation as much as maybe they could be. And I think it's a bit of a paradox with society and clinical psychology. It's a bit of, it's the other way I feel. Yeah, and it's definitely, I hear you. Like, it's really hard when you are striving in a career to be vulnerable enough that that's seen as good.
并试图让所有人都能无障碍地参与。但不幸的是，我觉得男性并没有像他们本可以的那样多地被纳入到这种对话中。我认为这有点像社会与临床心理学之间的一个悖论。我觉得情况刚好反过来了。是的，我完全理解你的感受。当你为了事业而奋斗时，要脆弱到被认为表现良好，这真的很难。
That's very good. And not so vulnerable that you're unhinged and need a safeguarding referral put in and you don't then get a reference. Like it's striking that magic balance. And yeah, it's like it's that power dynamic, isn't it? That actually especially as an assistant that you don't always have.
这种脆弱必须恰到好处：不能脆弱到精神崩溃、需要转介安全保障服务的地步，以至于拿不到推荐信。就像是在走钢丝，要达到那个神奇的平衡。是的，这就像是那种权力动态，对吧？特别是在作为助理的时候，你并不总是拥有这种权力。
And I think my experiences of then moving on to training and I had six different supervisors during my time and very quickly having to forge working relationships with those some more successfully than others and still having that power held over you, you know, you haven't been there yet because you're yet to start your first placement, but there will be likely a mid-placement review and during that mid-placement review, a question will be asked,
我想我转入培训后的经历是这样的：我在实习期间有六个不同的督导，我不得不非常迅速地与他们建立工作关系，有些比另一些更成功，而且你头顶上始终悬着那种权力。你知道的，你还没有经历过这个，因为你还没有开始你的第一次实习，但很可能会有一个实习中期评估，而在那个实习中期评估期间，会有人问这样一个问题：
is there any chance that Jack could fail this placement? I can tell you that, you know, when you're waiting for that answer, you're like, oh, my God. And once you hear, hopefully, no, you're like, and then you really can be thinking about how to, you know, meet your goals and finish this placement on a high. But you are constantly assessed for those three years. Yes, it's not something I've thought about too much in fairness. but I think given given like you said it's been a long time getting on the course and that comes with lots of different assistant psychology roles that's that's certainly going to be that's certainly going to help me on the on the course I think I'm kind of used to changing and working
杰克有没有可能通不过这次实习？我可以告诉你，你知道的，当你等待那个答案的时候，你会想：天哪。一旦你听到希望是“不会”的回答时，你会松一口气，然后你就可以真正考虑如何实现你的目标，圆满完成这次实习。但在那三年里，你始终在接受评估。是的，说实话，这并不是我考虑得太多的事情。不过我想，既然如你所说，进入这个课程花了很长时间，伴随着许多不同的心理学助理角色，这肯定会对我在这门课程中有所帮助。我想我已经习惯了经常更换并
in different teams quite frequently there's very yeah there's I've worked in all the big settings really I've worked in older adult child and family there's a comment in adult psychology so I've kind of got lots of skills like I can always lean back on. But being assessed is something new again. Having that conversation is going to be difficult. Yes, I haven't thought about it. So it's going to be, it's going to be interested and how I deal with maybe criticism and rooms for improvement. I think there'll be something I'll have to get used to. Not many, I think with assistant psychologists, it's often very positive. They want to build you up and make you feel more confident.
在不同的团队中工作。是的，我在所有的大型机构都工作过，我做过老年人、儿童和家庭心理学，还有成人心理学，所以我掌握了很多技能，随时可以依靠。但再次接受评估是一件新鲜事。进行那样的对话将会是困难的。是的，我之前没有考虑过这一点。所以这将是很有趣的，我将如何应对批评和改进的空间。我想这是我必须习惯的事情。我认为对于心理学助理来说，情况通常是非常积极的。他们希望培养你，让你感到更有自信。
thought about that to you honest marian so however yeah well food for thought but um do do allow yourself to grow into these new roles i think we can often put ourselves a lot of pressure on ourselves to go into a placement feeling like we are the expert at that already or that we should be better you know and i think almost one of the most powerful placement experiences i had was intellectual disabilities because I had never worked in that setting. And so I actually went in feeling like a bit of a fraud, actually. How am I going to go and deliver anything of substance when I just I've got to start from zero really. But when I allowed myself to do that and I, you know, I was honest on day one with my supervisor, I've never done this before. I don't really, I don't really know what I'm doing.
老实说，玛丽安，我以前没怎么想过这个问题。不过，是的，这确实值得深思。但是，请允许自己在这些新角色中成长。我想我们常常会给自己施加很大的压力，带着自己已经是那里的专家的心态去实习，或者觉得自己本该表现得更好。我想，我经历过的最有力的实习体验之一其实是在智力障碍服务部门，因为我从来没有在那个环境工作过。所以当我进去的时候，实际上感觉自己有点像个骗子。当我从零开始的时候，我怎么能提供任何有实质内容的东西呢？但当我允许自己这样做时，我在第一天就对我的督导坦白了：我以前从未做过这个，我真的不知道自己在做什么。
And maybe I haven't even ever really applied for roles, even as assistance with people with intellectual disabilities, because A, I didn't think I'd get them. And B, it wasn't really one of my passions, you know? So now I'm delivering a service to people and to their families. And my supervisor was so kind and so sweet and just allowed me to grow. And actually, when my placement was finished, they were like, we would love to have you back as qualified. and they were trying to put a job together so that it would be ready
也许我甚至从来没有申请过智力障碍人群助理之类的工作，因为A，我觉得自己不会被录取；B，这其实不是我的热情所在，你知道的。所以现在我在为人们和他们的家人提供服务。我的督导非常善良、非常贴心，只是让我去成长。实际上，当我实习结束时，他们说：我们很希望你能在毕业后作为合格的专业人员回来。他们甚至在试图筹备一个职位，以便在我完成培训时资金能够到位。
so that it would have gone through the funding by the time I finished training. And unfortunately, it just wasn't ready. It wasn't ready for another sort of six months after I qualified. So I already had a job, but they still contacted me and said, it's ready, it's going out to advert, will you apply? And I was like, I'm really sorry, like,
这样等我毕业后大约六个月就能通过审批了。所以我当时已经有了一份工作，但他们还是联系我说：岗位准备好了，马上就要发布招聘广告了，你会申请吗？而我当时的想法是：真的很抱歉，像...
I don't feel like I can now. But that is, if we allow ourselves to grow and we are maybe open about what we don't yet know. We can grow beyond where we would have imagined we might be able to be. That's, I guess, the value in allowing yourself to be curious and allowing yourself to grow and maybe being a little bit open. Yeah, I think that's the subtle differences in it between placements and assistance like Alders roles.
我觉得我现在不行了。但如果我们允许自己成长，并且对我们还不知道的事情保持开放的心态。我们可以超越我们原本想象的自己。我想，这就是允许自己保持好奇、允许自己成长、也许稍微开放一点的价值所在。是的，我认为这是实习和像阿尔德斯（Alders）职位这样的助理工作之间微妙的区别。
In a strange way, you haven't paying a hat to go into that job like you would do with an assistant. and you haven't applied for it, said why you're going to be great at it, and then go to do it. Whereas with the placements, you kind of, you're put into it, you've applied for clinical psychology, so you've been honest about that, but then when you're placing that placement, then maybe you don't feel confident,
从某种奇怪的角度来说，去做那份工作时你不需要像对待助理那样戴着有色眼镜，你也没有申请过它，没有说过你为什么会擅长它，然后就去做了。而在实习中，你有点像是被安排进去的，你申请了临床心理学，所以你对此很坦诚，但当你被分配到那个实习岗位时，也许你觉得没有信心，
or maybe you don't think you're going to enjoy. But that's not you being disingenuous or, you know, anything like that, it's kind of, well, this is how I feel, but I think, like you said, it is important to go in with an open mind. It's absolutely been in that position where maybe some of the roles, I thought I was going to join, maybe it didn't enjoy as much as I thought, and vice versa.
或者也许你觉得你不会喜欢。但这不是你在假装或者做作，或者诸如此类的事情，这有点像，嗯，我是这么觉得的，但我认为，就像你说的，带着开放的心态去面对是很重要的。我绝对经历过那种情况，有些我以为我会喜欢的角色，也许并没有我想象的那么喜欢，反之亦然。
And, yeah, I think when I've worked in intellectual disabilities, I had a similar feeling. How am I going to work with this clientele? I haven't got loads of experience. Everyone seems to really know what they're doing. But then when you keep that open mind and you learn and pick up skills, I think I probably learned so much more on those roles than maybe my other roles because I was soaking everything up and trying to learn as much as I can just so I can do the job, really. and it wasn't as scary and it wasn't as different as I thought it was going to be really
而且，是的，我想当我从事智力障碍相关的工作时，我有过类似的感觉。我将如何与这些客户群体合作？我没有丰富的经验。每个人似乎都很清楚自己在做什么。但当你保持开放的心态去学习和掌握技能时，我想我在那些角色中学到的东西可能比我的其他角色要多得多，因为我一直在疯狂地吸收知识，并试图尽可能多地学习，这样我才能真正做好这份工作。而且它并没有我想象的那么可怕，也没有我想象的那么不同。
and you're still able to bring all those skills and experience you've got from other roles into that role that maybe seems so different to what I've done before as well. Absolutely. We've got those core skills and our own personhood that we bring with us. And, you know, I think even every supervision session you've ever had and every supervisor you ever had, they're kind of in the room with you as well. So it's not that you're starting completely from zero. You've still got your soft skills. You've still got ways of being.
而且你仍然能够把你从其他角色中获得的所有那些技能和经验带入到这个角色中，而这个角色可能看起来和我以前做过的事非常不同。绝对是的。我们拥有那些核心技能以及我们自身的个性，我们会把这些带在身边。而且，你知道，我认为甚至你经历过的每一次督导和每一位督导，他们也某种程度上和你共处一室。所以并不是说你完全从零开始。你仍然拥有你的软技能。你仍然拥有自己的处事方式。
And obviously, even people with intellectual disabilities, you're often working with their families. They're often not intellectually disabled themselves. And so there's lots of transferable skills. But, yeah, you've reminded me, actually, in my first placement, I found it really challenging to not have been chosen. Yeah, that's the other side of the client, I suppose.
而且显然，即使是面对智力障碍人士，你通常也是在与他们的家属合作。他们自己通常并没有智力障碍。所以这里有很多可迁移的技能。但是，是的，你其实提醒了我，在我的第一份实习中，我发现对于没有被主动选择这一点，我真的很难接受。是的，我想这是硬币的另一面。
Yeah, you haven't been chosen. And knowing that I'm filling the shoes of someone that's just left, and I'm filling the shoes of a first year who has done two placements already, and I'm coming in as a first year first placement. I found it really hard. I don't know if it's my ego, I'm not sure, but I found it really hard. Because obviously in assistant roles, you are chosen, because probably there's been 150 people apply,
是的，你没有被选中。而且我知道我在接替一个刚刚离开的人，我是在接替一个已经完成两次实习的大一学生，而我作为一个大一学生的第一份实习就进来了。我发现这真的很难。我不知道是不是因为我的自尊心，我不太确定，但我真的觉得很难。因为很显然在助理岗位上，你是被选中的，因为可能有150个人申请过，
and you're the cream of the crop. it almost maybe develops this slightly narcissistic, you know, I've been chosen so I can go in there and I can feel a bit more confident and self-assured. I wasn't chosen. Not by this, not by this woman anyway. You know, some of the people that interviewed me, they chose me. You know, I haven't been chosen. I could have been anyone. Maybe they'd have preferred someone else. And then you find yourself sitting there and you think, oh yeah, that person from my cohort, they would probably have fitted in better here than me. And it's a lot of noise. but we can notice those thoughts.
而你是其中的佼佼者。它几乎会让人滋生出一种略带自恋的心态，你知道的，我被选中了，所以我可以进去，并且能感到更有自信和笃定。我没有被选中。至少不是被这个人，不是被这个女人。你知道的，面试我的某些人，他们选择了。你知道，我没有被选中。我可能是任何人。也许他们会更喜欢别人。然后你会发现自己坐在那里，心想，哦，是的，我同届的那个家伙，他可能比我更适合这里。这真是一种精神内耗，但我们可以注意到这些想法。
We can notice them and not hopefully be derailed by them. Yeah, yeah, I sent an email to my, so we had our placements this week and I sent an email to my new supervisor. And it was almost like, part of me was thinking when I send this email, I want to come across as quite competent
我们可以注意到它们，并希望不会被它们带偏。是的，是的，我给我的……所以我们这周有了实习分配，我给我的新督导发了一封电子邮件。几乎可以说是，当我发这封电子邮件时，我内心的一部分想法是，我想表现得相当胜任，
and I'm going to be okay, I can do this job, don't worry, I'm not completely useless. I think I mentioned I've worked in this service before and I probably said that just so she doesn't, think, oh, I've got this person doesn't know anything. At least I'm going in with a little bit of a knowledge and, you know, I'm not, I'm going to be able to do the job somewhat, so kind of don't worry sort of thing. But it was an unusual, yeah, it's an unusual situation to be in.
并且我会没事的，我能胜任这份工作，别担心，我不是完全无用的。我想我提到过我以前在这个服务机构工作过，我可能这么说只是为了让她不要觉得，“哦，我招了个什么都不懂的人”。至少我带着一点知识进去，而且，你知道的，我不会……我能在某种程度上胜任这份工作，所以有点像是“别担心”这种感觉。但这是一个不寻常的，是的，这是一个不寻常的处境。
And I suppose, yeah, your ego does come and do it a little bit because you want to be, you want to be okay doing the job really, and you want to be valued and not made to feel like you shouldn't be there. Yeah, I had a slightly cringy moment then, just thinking back. So I've been given a time and a date and a location to go, meet my first ever supervisor but i like i maybe i worried that i wasn't going to be held in mind um or that i needed something like extra so i did actually make contact with i think i emailed my supervisor or called them and left a message or something like that um and they're like
我想，是的，你的自尊心确实会作祟一点，因为你希望自己能行，你希望自己能够胜任这份工作，你希望自己受到重视，而不是让人觉得你不应该待在那里。是的，回想起来，我当时有过一个稍微有点尴尬的时刻。所以当时我被给了一个去见我的第一位督导的时间、日期和地点，但我可能担心自己不会被放在心上，或者我需要一些额外的东西，所以我确实联系了，我想我给我的督导发了邮件或打了电话并留了言之类的，然后他们的反应是
yeah yeah did you not get the message about the time and the day i was like yeah yes but like okay i see you know because ordinarily plans aren't made for us are they we we make our own plans or all the person has made them directly with us or sent it to us and it's come kind of vicariously round the houses and i just needed to i needed to be seen a bit more um but thank she didn't she didn't hold that against me yeah it's unusual it's a start a place when you haven't met the person before so obviously with your assistant roles you would have met them in an interview or had a chat beforehand can we sort of dbs check out where do i get my laptop from i don't think i don't think we're going to do that for this you just kind of turn on the day
“啊，是的，难道你没有收到关于时间和日期的信息吗？”我的反应是“啊，是的，但是……好吧，我明白了”。因为通常情况下，计划不会为我们做好，对吧？我们要么自己做计划，要么对方直接和我们一起制定计划或者发送给我们，而这事却兜了个圈子，通过间接的方式传到了我这里，我只是需要……我需要稍微多获得一点关注，不过谢天谢地，她并没有因为这个而对我有意见。是的，这是一种不同寻常的体验，当你之前从未见过这个人时就要开始一份实习。所以显然在你的助理岗位上，你会在面试中见过他们或者事先聊过，我们可以顺便搞定DBS背景调查，我从哪里拿我的笔记本电脑？我想……我觉得我们不会为这个做这些，你只要在当天露面就行了
and you probably turn up, nobody knows who you are. You've got an awkward conversation with the receptionist. Hi, I'm Jack. I'm here for my first day. Jack, who are you here to see? And you're like, thinking of the name is, I think it's Ali. I think that's her name. It's always uncomfortable the first day.
而且你很可能会去到那里，没有人知道你是谁。你和前台进行了一次尴尬的对话。嗨，我是杰克。我来报到第一天。杰克，你是来见谁的？然后你在脑子里想那个名字，我想是阿里。我想那是她的名字。第一天总是很不舒服。
But that's something I've got used to anyway. I think you've just got to go in knowing it's not, it's probably not going to go smoothly. It's going to be a bit chaotic on the first day. Hopefully I'm wrong, but probably right. You never know. You know, I've joined some services that are like that. I've joined others that you turn up and on day one,
但这也是我已经习惯的事情。我想你只要带着一种认知去就行了，那就是事情可能……可能不会那么顺利。第一天会有点混乱。希望我是错的，但大概我是对的。你永远说不准。你知道，我加入过一些这样的服务机构。我也加入过其他机构，你一去到那里，在第一天，
there's 12 folders on your desk and you're like, oh, okay, they did know, they didn't know I was coming. Now I've got to get up to speed. So yeah, it's all placements are so different, but just go with it and be curious, be reflective, if you can, and just allow yourself to grow, to learn, to develop and know that all of those great skills that you spoke about, you know, even stuff that you've done with the coaching for your academy, all of that is with you, all the boys you've worked with, they want you to do really, really well, as does everyone else who knows you, and we're all rooting for you as well, Jack. So I hope placement one and beyond goes so well for you.
你的桌子上有12个文件夹，你会想，“哦，好吧，他们确实知道……他们知道我要来。”现在我得赶上进度了。所以，是的，所有的实习都非常不同，但顺其自然，保持好奇，如果可以的话，保持反思，只要允许自己成长、学习、发展，并知道你所谈论的所有那些伟大的技能——你知道的，甚至是你为你的学院做过的辅导之类的事情——所有这些都伴随着你，你合作过的所有那些人，他们都希望你做得非常非常出色，所有其他认识你的人也是如此，我们都在为你加油，杰克。所以我希望你的第一份实习以及未来的实习一切顺利。
Thank you so much for joining us, Jack. Thanks very much. Thank you again to my guest today, Jack. The kindest thing you can do is to go wild in the comments with support, with encouragement, with how this resonated for you. And I know that Jack would be really pleased to see those comments as well. You can do that on YouTube. you can do that on Spotify.
非常感谢你加入我们，杰克。非常感谢。再次感谢我今天的嘉宾杰克。你能做的最善良的事就是在评论区疯狂留言，给予支持、鼓励，分享这些内容是如何引起你的共鸣的。我知道杰克看到这些评论也会非常高兴。你可以在YouTube上留言，也可以在Spotify上留言。
Thank you so much for watching this episode. If you found it helpful, I would love it if you consider following or subscribing to the show wherever you watch or listen. It's the kindest thing you can do for any creator that you rate. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step in this wild old ride of psychology,
非常感谢你观看本期节目。如果你觉得有帮助，无论你在哪里观看或收听，我都希望你能考虑关注或订阅这个节目。这是你能为你所欣赏的任何创作者做的最善良的事。如果时机成熟，你已经准备好在这场心理学疯狂之旅中迈出下一步，
do consider coming along to the aspiring psychologist membership. You can join from £30 a month with no minimum term and it's never the right or wrong stage of your career to join. It's never too early. It's never too late. Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this.
不妨考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（aspiring psychologist membership）。你只需每月30英镑起即可加入，没有最低期限限制，而且无论处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，加入的时机永远谈不上对或错。永远不会太早。永远不会太晚。嗨，我叫贝丝（Beth），我是来自纽卡斯尔的一名心理健康从业者。我只想向《临床心理学家集锦》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书的撰稿人们表达最诚挚的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，并且很高兴能深入了解大家在申请博士学位之前拥有的各种背景和经历。了解申请过程中可能存在的障碍以及我如何尝试克服这些障碍，真的非常有趣。
I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate. But this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我开始真正怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否有资格申请临床心理学博士学位。但这确实给了我迈出这一步所需的信心。所以，致以我最诚挚的谢意。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。